just hearing that the former japanese
prime minister shinzo abe has been shot
during a speech in the city of nara
what's happening how is he let's find
out nicole standing by hi nicole
well we have some video that has been
captured
uh showing some indication of what
happened during that attack you can see
shinzo abe
addressing the crowds he was on the
campaign trail a shot is heard
and then a suspect is wrestled to the
ground he was later airlifted out
officials say that his heart has stopped
the fire department of the city has also
confirmed that he was in cardio and
pulmonary
arrest now local media says that a 42
year old man has been arrested that he
used a homemade gun and that he told
police that he was unhappy with abe's
performance and that he intended to kill
him now this is an incredibly rare
unusual situation to be happening in
japan it's normally a very safe country
gun violence is rare political violence
is rare as well
we've also heard from japan's prime
minister fumio kashida
he has said that there will of course be
an investigation and he wants to believe
that the security was sufficient and
he's condemned the act in the strongest
terms
more international reaction is coming
out because shinzei abe
uh was really had global stature he was
a major figure on the international
stage during his long tenure as japan's
prime minister we've heard from boris
johnson he said that he's utterly
appalled by this attack calling it
despicable
also the u.s secretary of state anthony
blinken speaking at the g20 foreign
ministers meeting in bali has said that
thoughts and prayers are with his
his family and the people of japan at
this time
also the u.s ambassador to japan
recognizing that shinzo abe was an
outstanding leader and an unwavering
ally of the united states so many
questions are going to be asked about
how such a incredible security breach
could have happened because looking at
that video it appears that the attack
took place in close range
there doesn't appear to have been a
great deal of security
around but more international reaction
will come out during the day
shinzei abe was prime minister of japan
twice as i said the longest serving
leader he steered the country through
through a difficult
economic period
when the economy was stagnating and
aging population in effect he formed his
own economic policy which in the end was
known as abeonomics
okay thanks so much indeed nicole thank
you obviously we'll continue to update
you on the condition of mr arby who has
been shot
during a presentation within the last
few hours